the u.s has got a road deaths problem in
the first nine months of 2021 an
estimated 31 000 people were killed on
u.s roads it's a 12 increase on the same
period the year before and the largest
surge in fatalities since reporting
began we have a crisis that is urgent
unacceptable and
preventable one major cause of those
deaths is speeding according to the u.s
department of transportation speeding
killed nearly a hundred thousand people
on u.s roads over the past decade and
played a role in more than a quarter of
traffic deaths in 2020. now to try and
reduce the number of deaths that
department is assigning billions to try
and get americans to drive safer and
slower but changing how fast america
drives might not be as simple as just
changing the speed limit it involves
understanding the psychology behind why
we speed and re-examining the somewhat
controversial way that america's speed
limits have been set in the past a lot
of people believe we say let's set the
speed limit there and design the road
around it we actually do the exact
reverse so how exactly are speed limits
set in america and what can be done to
prevent so many deaths on u.s roads well
let's find out
okay first thing to understand is that
the speed limit on a lot of american
roads is actually decided after that
road has been built and it's often
decided using something called the 85th
percentile rule so let's say we've just
opened this stretch of road here
authorities will monitor the speed that
cars naturally travel down this road
crucially that speed is often a factor
of the layout of the road wide straight
and open roads encourage higher speeds
the speed that 85 percent of people are
naturally driving at or under then
becomes the speed limit let's say in
this case it's 30 miles per hour but
there's a bit of a problem with the 85th
percentile rule here's beth osborne from
transportation for america with why so
sometimes you start to design that road
and you're like oh
that road was designed for 30 miles per
hour but people tend to be using it at
35 we should probably give them a little
more space because at 35 they're gonna
start to make mistakes we weren't
anticipating we need to make sure the
buildings are further back we need a
good clear zone so that you know if
someone loses control they can drive off
the roadway and not hit anything and so
you got to get rid of trees
and light poles then everything they do
to quote accommodate
that new speed
actually encourages more speeding and
then the next time you do a speed study
they say oh we can't keep the speed
limit at 35 because 25 of people going
above that so it's this reactive chain
of events that constantly pushes um the
uh the speed limit up so if america's
speeds are determined by the speed that
people naturally want to drive at but
that speed is potentially killing people
what can be done well recently u.s
transportation secretary pete boudija
said he wanted to get the number of
deaths on america's roads down to zero
our goal is zero deaths
to do that he's unveiled a five billion
dollar strategy to try and make
america's cars roads and drivers safer
now the plan has its critics from those
who say zero deaths is impossible to
those who say it's not doing enough but
the thing that caught my interest was
this one line in the safer speeds
section where it says roadway design and
other infrastructure factors play a
significant role in managing speeds and
can deter excessive speeding see in the
same way that making roads more open and
wider can lead to faster roads if
they're on a road that is narrower that
maybe has a median where there's parking
along the sides where there's trees
along the side if you feel like you're
being hugged in
you naturally without being asked to go
slower yep it may seem counter-intuitive
but making those wide open streets a
little narrower and a little tighter
may actually make them safer so that
design makes a huge difference and that
attitude has been missing from a lot of
american safety so are we likely to
suddenly see roads across the u.s become
narrower and filled with trees and
curbside shops anytime soon well
according to beth if the biden
administration wants to slow down
america's roads to potentially save
lives it's gonna have to do so quickly
you've got to slowly rehab our entire
massive national transportation system
which isn't going to happen overnight
but mass infrastructure change can be a
huge expensive task and while some
streets may change in the short term
it's unclear what the longer term
effects of this plan could be or how
many lives it could save it's still a 10
to 20 year process
and you know if they lose this window
that 10 to 20 years again if there's a
change of leadership or something shifts
can turn into 40 years like that so in
the interim it's going to be up to the
drivers themselves to try and reduce the
number of accidents so drive safe folks
hey thanks for watching so do you think
the speed limit on america's road should
be reassessed let me know in the
comments below and as always if you're
interested in the future of how we might
be getting from a to b then don't forget
to subscribe see you soon
[Music]